well monetary policy that's a that's a
very good question I think that what the
Fed has done so far which is to provide
investment banks and other financial
institutions which have played an
important role in the economy and an
important role in in the functioning of
the whole credit system providing them
with access to liquidity with access to
the Federal Reserve's borrowing facility
and some of the innovations that they
have done in that respect are very good
I don't think that more cuts in federal
funds rate are called for I think
there's a there's a significant risk of
inflation in the current situation and
so I think the Fed's monetary policy is
not going to continue to cut short term
interest rates now the problem is that
that what the Fed did for example in the
case of bear stearns providing the and
in the immediate aftermath of the Bear
Stearns Collette collapse providing
access to the discount window boring
facility for investment banks that was
the right thing but that was an
innovation and policy and what I think
needs to happen is that there needs to
be some further thought given to the
supervisory and regulatory function of
the Fed over institutions like that to
go along with this access to to the feds
credit
I tend to not see political solutions to
problems like this I believe in the
Independence of the Federal Reserve but
what I do believe is that the next
president ought to take some clues from
the proposals that the Treasury
secretary and this Blue Ribbon
Commission just put forth to revise the
the regulatory system for financial
institutions and the economy I think
that needs a little bit of rethinking
and I think the next president will take
that seriously will have to take that
seriously whoever that that is